>>
>> SEX TOY OR DOG TOY?
( LAUGHTER ).
>> CAN'T IT BE BOTH?
>> I THINK IT JUST DEPENDS ON
WHICH ORDER YOU START.
>> I WANT TO SHOW YOU THE
HEADLINE FOR USER REVIEW ON
AMAZON.
YOU TELL ME IF THIS IS A REVIEW
FOR A DOG TOY OR SEX TOY.
IT'S WORTH TWO OF 50 POINTS.
THE LITTLE SPINY THINGS ARE TOO
SHARP.
SEX TOY OR DOG TOY.
JUNE.
>> DOG TOY.
>> THAT IS A DOG TOY, YES.
A DINOSAUR CHEW POINT.
>> 1500 POINT.
>> YOU GET 250.
I LIKE THIS NAME YOUR OWN SCORE
GAME THAT YOU'RE PLAYING RIGHT
NOW.
YOU'RE DOING FINE.
IT'S CHEAP PLASTIC AND SMELLS TO
HIGH HEAVEN.
MIKE LAWRENCE?
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH DOG TOYS
BECAUSE ALL DOGS GO TO HIGH
HEAVEN.
>> THAT WAS AN ADORABLE WAY TO
SAY THAT.
THAT'S AN INCORRECT ANSWER.
THAT WAS A SEX TOY.
IT KIBE DOG TOY.
IT COULD BE.
>> IS IT USED?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S USED OR
NOT.
>> WHY DOES IT STOIRCHG HIGH
HEAV JEAN THEY WEREN'T SPECIFIC
ABOUT WHICH POINT IN THE PROCESS
THEY SMELLED IT?
THAT COULD BE USER ERROR.
>> THIS LARGE BLACK ONE WAS
FINALLY INDESTRUCTIBLE.
JAMES ADOMIAN.
>> DOG AND SEX TOY.
>> IT COULD BE BOTH BUT IT IS A
DOG TOY.
>> THAT COULD BE BOTH.
THAT COULD GO ALL KINDS OF
PLACES.
♪ WEREWOLVES OF LONDON ♪ ♪.
>> I'D BE FOAMING HE MOUTH.